So now let's build an equation
to predict points scored
using some common
basketball statistics.
So our dependent variable
would now be points,
and our independent
variables would
be some of the common
basketball statistics
that we have in our data set.
So for example, the number of
two-point field goal attempts,
the number of three-point
field goal attempts,
offensive rebounds,
defensive rebounds,
assists, steals,
blocks, turnovers,
free throw attempts--
we can use all of these.
So let's build this regression
and call it PointsReg.
And that will just be equal
to lm of PTS regressing
on all those variables
we just talked about.
So X2PA for two-point
attempts, plus X3PA
for three-point attempts, plus
FTA for free throw attempts,
AST for assists, ORB
offensive rebounds,
DRB for defensive rebounds,
TOV for turnovers,
and STL for steals.
And let's also throw
in blocks, BLK.
Okay.
And as always, the data
is from the NBA data set.
So we can go ahead
and run this command.
So now that we've created
our points regression model,
let's take a look
at the summary.
This is always the first
thing you should do.
Okay, so taking a
look at this, we
can see that some of our
variables are indeed very,
very, significant.
Others are less significant.
For example, steals only
has one significance star.
And some don't seem to
be significant at all.
For example, defensive
rebounds, turnovers, and blocks.
We do have a pretty good
R-squared value, 0.8992,
so it shows that there really
is a linear relationship
between points and all of
these basketball statistics.
Let's compute the
residuals here.
We can just do that by
directly calling them,
so that's PointsReg$residuals.
So there's this
giant list of them,
and we'll use this to compute
the sum of squared errors.
SSE, standing for sum
of squared errors,
is just equal to the
sum(PointsReg$residuals^2).
So what is the sum of
squared errors here?
It's quite a lot-- 28,394,314.
So the sum of
squared errors number
is not really a very
interpretable quantity.
But remember, we
can also calculate
the root mean
squared error, which
is much more interpretable.
It's more like the average error
we make in our predictions.
So the root mean squared error,
RMSE-- let's calculate it here.
So RMSE is just equal
to the square root
of the sum of squared
errors divided by n,
where n here is the number
of rows in our data set.
So the RMSE in
our case is 184.4.
So on average, we make an
error of about 184.4 points.
That seems like quite a
lot, until you remember that
the average number of points
in a season is, let's see,
mean(NBA$PTS).
This will give us the average
number of points in a season,
and it's 8,370.
So, okay, if we have an average
number of points of 8,370,
being off by about 184.4
points is really not so bad.
But I think we still have room
for improvement in this model.
If you recall, not all the
variables were significant.
Let's see if we can remove some
of the insignificant variables
one at a time.
We'll take a look
again at our model,
summary(PointsReg),
in order to figure out
which variable we
should remove first.
The first variable we
would want to remove
is probably turnovers.
And why do I say turnovers?
It's because the p value for
turnovers, which you see here
in this column, 0.6859, is the
highest of all of the p values.
So that means that turnovers
is the least statistically
significant variable
in our model.
So let's create a new regression
model without turnovers.
An easy way to do this
is just to use your up
arrow on your
keyboard, and scroll up
through all of your
previous commands
until you find the command
where you defined the regression
model.
Okay, so this is the command
where we defined the model.
Now let's delete turnovers, and
then we can rename the model,
and we'll call this
one just PointsReg2.
So in our first regression
model, PointsReg,
we had an R-squared of 0.8992.
Let's take a look at the
R-squared of PointsReg2.
And we see that it's 0.8991.
So almost exactly identical.
It does go down, as we
would expect, but very, very
slightly.
So it seems that we're
justified in removing turnovers.
Let's see if we can
remove another one
of the insignificant variables.
The next one, based on p-value,
that we would want to remove
is defensive rebounds.
So again, let's
create our model,
taking out defensive rebounds,
and calling this PointsReg3.
We'll just scroll up again.
Take out DRB, for
defensive rebounds,
and change the name
of this to PointsReg3
so we don't
overwrite PointsReg2.
Let's look at the
summary again to see
if the R-squared has changed.
And it's the same, it's 0.8991.
So I think we're justified again
in removing defensive rebounds.
Let's try this one more time
and see if we can remove blocks.
So we'll remove blocks,
and call it PointsReg4.
Take a look at the
summary of PointsReg4.
And again, the R-squared
value stayed the same.
So now we've gotten down to a
model which is a bit simpler.
All the variables
are significant.
We've still got an
R-squared 0.899.
And let's take a look now
at the sum of squared errors
and the root mean
square error, just
to make sure we
didn't inflate those
too much by removing
a few variables.
So, remember that the sum
of squared errors that we
had in the original model was
this giant number, 28,394,314.
And the root mean squared error,
the much more interpretable
number, was 184.4.
So those are the numbers we'll
be comparing against when
we calculate the new
sum of squared errors
of the new model, PointsReg4.
So let's call this SSE_4.
And that will just be equal to
sum(PointsReg4$residuals^2).
And then RMSE_4 will just be
the square root of SSE_4 divided
by n, the number of
rows in our data set.
Okay, so let's take
a look at these.
The new sum of squared
errors is now 28,421,465.
Again, I find this very
difficult to interpret.
I like to look at the root
mean squared error instead.
So the root mean squared
error here is just RMSE_4,
and so it's 184.5.
So although we've increased
the root mean squared error
a little bit by removing
those variables,
it's really a very,
very, small amount.
Essentially, we've kept the root
mean squared error the same.
So it seems like we've narrowed
down on a much better model
because it's simpler,
it's more interpretable,
and it's got just about
the same amount of error.